now fans know that matt james's season
is not filming at the iconic bachelor
mansion but
since we are here i'm gonna get to take
a look around
we are inside the bachelor mansion
everybody and fans will remember
these stairs tiara infamously fell
down them during sean low season tierra
i'm in heels
they seem pretty sturdy to me
now we're at the point where this is my
least favorite part of the night
now we are entering hallowed grounds
this
is the famous rose ceremony room of
course it looks totally different right
now but
if you recognize the fireplace behind me
earlier in the night before the
eliminations happen
a kiss or an intimate chat might happen
there
and then people get sent home though
you'll notice not a rose in sight right
now because production changes
everything when they film
and that's why i brought some
i'm a jacket
all right we are here in the kitchen and
it actually gets put to a lot of use
because even though the show seems
glamorous
when you're a contestant you got to cook
your own food
[Music]
you're doing a lot of making out i don't
know are there mints all over the
bachelor mansion
um you know what there was there were
the listerine strips
everywhere everywhere and i definitely
use my fair share of them just pop those
in
oh hey guys bachelor nation we are in
the room known as the tink tink room
where chris harrison comes in
does a tink tank on his glass and makes
a dramatic announcement
sorry to break this up but it is time
for our first rose ceremony
ah the pool if you didn't jump in on
night one
were you even here
[Music]
that's it that's that's the most
important thing
yeah now many an intimate conversation
has happened at this fireplace i'm
really hoping to get the first
impression rose but if i don't
i brought my own yeah that's sad
we are now in the master bedroom closet
and behind the scenes secret
when chris harrison isn't filming he
takes naps in here so
let's see what it's like
not bad thanks
you grew up i mean just a few minutes
from where we are
at the bachelor mansion you said you
used to try to sneak in
does this mean did you ever daydream
about being bachelor and did you guys
ever think this could happen
life's crazy life is very crazy i swear
i have vivid memories of trying to hop
over that fence and sneak on here and
um this many years later having this
opportunity
i'm the most i'm the luckiest guy in the
world
i am with the man who designed it who
owned it and who is now renting it on
airbnb for you
marshall harridan i am noticing though i
kind of brought the roses today
not as many roses on property as we
usually see on a certain tv show do they
bring the roses in
what's the deal they bring their own
this is the first time it's ever been on
airbnb right
yes so what made you want to put it out
there uh
you know the kids are all grown up so
they're not here
there's a lot of empty house so we
travel a lot so when we come home we go
it's just sitting here empty so it's
right around 9 600 square feet
wow there is uh seven bedrooms now
and eight bathrooms okay um
it sits on 10 acres how many people are
you saying that it can sleep then
comfortably
i think we say 13. 13. usually 30 women
on the show
the pool gets used quite a lot
it does do you ever wonder what that
pool has seen i keep it really clean
okay so marshall i want to come and stay
one night how much am i looking at
just one night yeah well you have
political influence so
probably around six thousand dollars a
night six thousand dollars what do i get
two jacuzzis swimming pool pool table
full bar
chris harrison not included oh that's
extra
a lot
[Music]
you